Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 7th.
[inaudible] hey,
how's it going?
How are you driving to work?
Or you're already at work in your cubicle or your fucking off.
Are you bringing this country down by not doing your share of the workload
today?
Well,
who gives a shit if you work for somebody else?
The fuck?
Do you care?
I mean,
who's dream is it really?
Is it yours?
I don't think it is.
It's not your dream.
It's their dream.
You know?
What kind of office did you dream about as a child?
You had a fucking door.
The walls went all the way up to the ceiling.
You know,
you went in the middle of a fucking room,
you know,
with a four foot wall surrounding you on three sides,
completely vulnerable.
Anybody who went to West Point can tell you right now,
the debt is not a safe position and that you need to move.
You mean you need to move to higher ground.
Um,
I don't want to get involved in all of that crap.
It's a wonderful weekend.
The July 4th weekend,
the celebration of the independence of a,
this,
this wonderful nation.
Do you guys go to a parade?
What did you do?
Did you get hammered and watch some fireworks?
I actually,
one of my favorite things to do out here in,
uh,
in Los Angeles is on July 4th how everybody just shoots fireworks wherever the
fuck they want to.
And me and my wife and some friends every year we just go up onto the roof of my
house and we just sit there and we watch.
And fortunately none of my neighbors shoot any off.
It's always a couple blocks away.
And then just all the way across Dell a and we just just watch it.
I always tried to take a video,
but the cell phone just doesn't,
it doesn't do it justice.
And um,
then there's,
there's like a mall,
I don't know how far away it is.
Okay.
Say like,
I don't know,
three to five miles away.
They actually have one.
So right as we're getting on the roof,
they usually get into their finale cause you know,
people bring their kids to the mall.
You know one of those fucking malls that has like a trolley that drives around
it and they play like Tony Bennett Sinatra and everybody feels like,
you know,
like they're a winner is you're walking in and out of the gap.
Luck be a lady two night,
never let her out of my sight is overall so good at me.
He'll lab,
why don't you put them on you fucking Tba Shit.
Who is over law if you're not growing food,
if you're wearing overalls,
if you not in an early nineties R and B band,
you're basically wearing it because that's what your stomach feels comfortable
and you know,
it's like,
it's like you're pregnant as a guy.
Did he have one of those,
you know those satchels that people were,
you know where the one of those little swath fucking whatever it is,
it's like a blanket and it's like a paper route bag.
At the same time when there's like a baby in there,
all the baby in this case is your big fucking round stomach.
You know,
I want to try to fetch the shame.
Some people come on,
people make a keen was salad.
I guess Keno Wa even though it's spelled oh a is not the way to say it.
Some fucking asshole on Twitter's giving me shit.
You driving me crazy.
It's pronounced.
Woah.
What kind of a man knows how keenwah Okinawa is even fucking pronounced.
Okay.
You know what kind of man knows something like that besides an h and f is a
fucking somebody who's comfortable with themselves.
Somebody who realizes that meat is a lie.
Now I'm fucking with you.
I'm actually,
I've really cut down with my meat intake just out of pure vanity.
I love it.
You don't eat meat.
Your fucking stomach goes away.
The fat has nowhere to hide.
Or as they say in long island,
high tide,
it has no way to hide.
Um,
if,
um,
yeah,
it's got nowhere to fucking go.
I cooked this weekend like a,
a yoga instructor slash of fat.
Fuck.
You know,
I made,
my key was salad Kinawa however the fuck you saying,
I made that thing,
which is great.
Fills you up like pancake batter and you just pour it down your gullet and
you're like,
I'm good.
You know it's funny as they say,
it's a complete protein,
but you can add chicken to it.
In other words,
it's not a complete protein.
All right.
There you with your fucking stretchy pants in your bare feet.
Stop fucking saying it's a complete protein.
I know it isn't.
Okay.
And I made that and then,
uh,
and made this peaches and beach salad with goat cheese.
I said,
I don't give a fuck what you guys say.
You can call me a fucking Douche all day long.
A fucking twinkle toes.
I don't care.
It's great.
Fills me up and I wake up the next morning and my fucking white stomach's a
little smaller.
You have to try it.
I actually went to the grocery store and I bought organic beets where it had
like the fucking leaves,
like some asshole Asshole,
some migrant worker,
you know,
because America's though worth those jobs.
Lee grue beats of those goods.
We,
they'd be fluidly Lowe's beat.
MMM.
We actually had to pay people and we still kept our yards.
It would be $40 a beat.
Um,
can everybody explained to me the economics of that?
Why everything has to be done outside of this country?
Or it would be nine zillion dollars and don't even fucking just say it's because
of the unions.
I know it's partly because of that,
but the other part is those people with those fucking yachts that I saw in
Sandro pay,
in order for somebody to get a boat that fucking big legally without being a
fucking pirate,
there's gotta be somebody crying in a field and El Salvador,
Poland,
organic beets out of the fucking ground,
or allegedly organic beets out of the ground to the tune of about eight pesos a
fucking month.
Right?
Isn't that how it works?
I don't fucking know.
All I know is,
is something going on with all these gated communities?
We live in a gated community.
What the fuck are you doing?
Or what do you know that's going to happen?
And right there.
You're,
you're,
you're fucking,
uh,
what do you call those guys at not a build shit
Freemason.
I'd like how people get mad at free masons cause they know how to make shit and
they don't want to tell you about it.
You know,
don't you have a secret recipe with your barbecued ribs there?
where your fucking cream pie or whatever the hell you make.
Don't,
isn't that a secret family recipe?
Well,
the secret family recipe with the free masons is they understand how the
universe works and if they went and told you how the universe works,
next thing you know you're off the grid.
You know,
growing apples in your toaster,
you don't have to pay for electric power.
Why would you go to that cubicle with your four foot walls?
You wouldn't do it.
And then what would they be?
Where would their joy be
if they couldn't see you walking into a fucking building every day that you
didn't want to go to?
Where would their joy be?
What would fill up the dark souls?
What misery could they look at?
They were left to be tortured.
Like guess like torturing squirrels on their property.
Right.
You don't want to do out here.
I want to fucking go up to that.
I want to go up to that Hearst mansion.
MMM.
William Randolph Hearst,
whatever the fuck his name was.
He's like the original Rupert Murdoch and he fucking,
he owned all of this shit.
Why does Versie always call when I'm doing the podcast?
Um,
he's like the original,
uh,
what the fuck.
We're out Rupert Murdoch and he owned fucking everything.
Allegedly a citizen.
Kane was about him,
but he has,
he has the Hearst castle somewhere between here and San Francisco.
And uh,
it takes you like three days to get through it.
This was the guy's fucking house.
And I actually shot a,
a a scene one time,
not one time about,
um,
the last month who's getting home.
Uh,
also,
uh,
did a sketch for Kroll show.
I might as well hype dad.
I think Nicole is a fucking genius.
So I hope you guys watch the next season.
I got to do a little bit of acting work on that.
And,
uh,
we shot in a building that used to be owned by a William Randolph Hearst and
allegedly big word,
allegedly,
there was a secret elevator in there that old,
uh,
or Billy,
a not red face,
used to bring up his,
uh,
extra curricular sin,
you know,
with their fucking Louis really little buttons and whatever the fuck is fucking
horse.
He had a whore elevator.
That's when you know,
you got money,
you know,
I of all those MTV cribs and shack with this giant fucking bed,
right.
And fucking Redman with people sleeping on the floor of his fucking place.
You never saw anybody with a whore elevator to this day.
You know,
it's fucking brilliant.
The whore elevator,
when the fuck was the elevator invented?
That seems like some early 19 hundreds,
possibly late 18 hundreds type of shit,
you know,
and you know,
in the late 18 hundreds when they first came up with it,
they probably had like fucking six year olds pulling people up in it.
And it was completely legal.
Um,
but anyways,
this guy had a whore elevators.
So,
I mean,
if he had a whore elevator at fucking work,
I'm not going to look at his house.
I got to do it.
Um,
so anyways,
I've been off since I did my special and uh,
I actually got,
I'm finally gonna sit down and watch it tonight.
I made the lovely Nia promise me that you sit down and watch with me cause you
know,
it's not,
it's,
it's a fucking outer body experience.
All right?
It's one thing to take a video and look at it and we'll,
you know of yourself doing something dumb.
That's one thing.
But to know that a bunch of people are going to fucking see the thing that
really makes you,
it makes you a little bit nuts,
you know?
So I got all my other busy work out of the fucking way.
It's why I'm doing the podcast here Sunday night.
And um,
cause I know I got to get this fucking 800 pound gorilla off my shoulders.
I got to sit down and watch,
I gotta watch the fucking thing,
which I don't want to do.
Um,
Oh God,
I'm dreading that.
Anyways.
Uh,
the fuck was I talking about?
So I'm really enjoying just,
you know,
last since I got back from Vegas,
just not doing shit.
I didn't do shit all week other than a make my fucking twinkle toe stuff.
Oh.
And then I,
I also,
I made this fucking dessert.
I just love when you guys trash me for whatever I do.
Uh,
I made this chocolate chip cheesecake with a chocolate crust and I can't even
tell you guys how ridiculously excited I was to make my first like look like a
Brownie crust.
And I was always wondering how the fuck do you make the crust?
Why do you get the chocolate in there?
It's just like this cocoa powder.
You put a little bit in there,
then you sift the fucking thing down,
right?
You put in your fucking shortening.
I overcooked it.
How do you tell getting golden brown when it's chocolate?
You know?
Oh,
fucking get it.
Anyways,
so I ate one of those things today and I feel sick.
It was too much,
you know?
Okay.
Fucking too much.
What am I talking about?
I don't know what I'm talking about.
I'm on fucking vacation.
I'm living in my own goddamn world out here.
So,
uh,
other than that,
yeah,
I was,
I was hiking with my dog all this week.
We're still getting the work done in the house.
And I had the dog,
uh,
she stays at the vet during the day cause she gets freaked out when the workers
are making all that God damn noise.
And um,
so,
you know,
I was on the road getting ready to do the special and I hadn't seen her in like
a week and I came back and she was fucking fat.
Eight a fat people.
They love her over the vet and she loves them.
My dog loves anybody that takes care of him first.
She's like,
who the fuck are you within the second you take care of her,
she turns into a little lap dog and a,
so they love her to death.
So they're always giving her treats and I fucking see her.
I almost didn't recognize her.
You know what I mean?
You're like,
when you go to your high school reunion after 20 years and you really got to,
you got to kind of look,
does like a little part of the forehead and the eyes is where you can still see
the person that you used to know.
And um,
okay,
that's what I was doing.
So I went on a bunch of long hikes with my dog.
Fortunate,
she's a pit bull,
she's all my muscles and she's back in shape after like three,
four days.
And that was basically my weekend.
And um,
oh,
I forgot to mention.
So we ended up going up on the roof
to,
to watch the fucking fire works.
And uh,
so we go up there and everybody's shooting them off and everything.
And every year I sat and I go,
you know,
it's fucking amazing that all these people just randomly,
and this,
there's some people this shooting off some real shit,
not just like bottle rockets.
This shoot enough stuff that blows up and shoots out until like a ball,
you know.
And it usually happens,
you know,
I dunno,
two,
300 feet up off the ground.
They shoot him up and it goes off at like 75 feet off the fucking ground in
between these apartment buildings.
So I'm standing on the roof.
Okay.
And I'm literally saying to my wife,
I go,
you know,
it's unbelievable every year how all of these things get shut off and nobody
likes their high house on fire.
And within fucking two minutes to me saying that,
mmm,
I look in the distance and I'm thinking like,
wow,
that that firework is,
is lasting pretty long.
And I look at it and it has that undeniable orange glow slash dancing of fire.
And I'm like,
that's a fire.
Somebody let that fucking ass on fire.
Right?
And I look into them.
Sure enough,
I couldn't believe how fast it spread.
And next thing you know,
there's a helicopter flying around it.
And then you know,
off to the left,
we hear the fire engine starting come down.
And as fast as that thing lit ignited,
and as fast as it spread,
they fucking put that thing out.
I'm sure they,
you know,
drowned everything that anybody owned in the building,
but a,
they put it out pretty God damn quick.
And,
uh,
so I got video of it.
I don't know.
I mean maybe I'll put it up there.
I was actually talking to Virginia when I was on the phone.
I think I would,
it was him that I said,
maybe I'll,
I'll,
I'll post the video.
MMM.
It's not it,
but I,
you know,
I'm not going to post it because this is not a good video.
You know,
his fucking cell phone at night and this happened like in a,
probably a good mile and a half away,
whatever,
whatever.
So somebody looked at house on fire.
So that was,
that was interesting.
You know,
it was funny.
My mother in law was hilarious.
What she was just like saying something to the effect that the,
she'd wished the person did that later on during the fireworks show because none
of the fireworks could,
could follow.
Basically somebody lighting their house on fire.
If there was like way more exciting than then you went back to the fireworks.
It's just like,
Eh,
you know,
it's kind of like doing your closing joke in the middle of your act.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of like gang,
I don't know what the fuck else it's like.
So anyways,
um,
okay.
Do you think would have been rude of me if I,
I live right next to him and I put on ACDC houses on fire.
This house is on fire,
you know,
is their house was on fire.
No talking heads burning down the house with that.
But that big noxious,
I think it would be,
what is the proper music to play when you're,
when you fucking neighbors like their house on fire.
What is the respectful thing to do?
Is there,
is there some country song saying,
I'm sorry,
your trailers on final fucking,
I don't know.
This is the Monday morning podcast everybody.
And I'm like I said,
I'm doing it Sunday night and I don't have my,
um,
I don't have any advertising yet,
so I'm just gonna have to pause here cause I'm not the drop this shit.
And after I,
uh,
after I record shit.
So with that,
this is the Monday morning podcast and here's a couple of advertising Diddy's
for you and uh,
we'll be back after these messages from me in the future.
Hulu plus everybody,
you've probably tried Hulu on your computer,
but you know what?
Hulu plus is so much more with Hulu plus you can watch currencies and episodes
of your favorite shows like modern family,
the daily show and scandal and watch every episode of shows like Nashville lost
and doctor Ho you get ad free movies and kids shows to now more than ever,
there's so much to watch.
Take total control with Hulu plus to stream these shows and thousands more as
much as you want,
wherever you want.
Hulu plus works on your computer,
your smartphone,
Roku,
apple TV,
Xbox,
play station.
Pretty much any streaming device you already own.
You can even watch on phone or iPad while on the train at work,
at the dentist or in the bathroom,
you can even block off a day to binge.
You also get access to originals that you can't get anywhere else.
Check out the new show.
Deadbeat a comedy about a pot smoking guy who talks to ghost binge on all 10
episodes starting April 9th for only 799 a month.
Get your shows anytime,
anywhere.
That's like only a quarter a day.
Everybody,
come on right now.
Sign up on Hulu plus.com/bill or click on the banner on my website and get two
weeks full access,
completely free.
That's a whole extra week.
More with the special offer when you sign up at Hulu plus.com/bill.
So get with it and start screaming TB now with Hulu plus.
All right,
now I'm back.
Hey Ya.
About those reads.
Was I going to what?
Eh,
fuck you.
I suck every week,
but whatever.
I'm trying.
Okay,
so let's get down to brass tacks.
Let's talk about what went well.
What went on this week.
I was in our Las Vegas.
Um,
I boosted it up.
Okay.
And then I immediately went back on the wagon and I've been able to hold out.
I had one beer,
I had one beer last night.
That was it.
And,
um,
but I'm definitely going to stay back on the wagon because I don't want to
fucking,
uh,
you know,
I don't want to have a big booze head again.
They'd have to go through all that bullshit trying to lose the fucking way you
gotta.
You gotta fucking,
you've got to keep it in check.
You know,
I'm want to tell them this story on stage and his kind of bombing,
so maybe it's,
it's better for the podcast.
Do you know I was fucking driving right.
And I stopped at a red light,
you know,
four way stop.
So the person to the right of me,
you know,
he's got the green light and he makes a left in front of me and he was so
fucking fat.
He like leaned his head right down to his man boob and his arm out the window,
kind of holding on to the car as he was picking terror.
So basically he wouldn't roll over and fucking crushes passenger.
Yeah,
I mean at what point do you just say,
all right,
okay.
I guess it really is like a drug addict.
I mean,
you see a fucking drug addict laying in the God damn street going over and
taking a dump on a fucking,
I dunno what Shrub.
At what point do you like,
like,
dude,
I,
I sleep on a sidewalk and I shit outside before you like,
hey,
you know what,
maybe I,
uh,
you know,
kind of knocked down the whole fucking heroin use.
Maybe ought to take it down a few notches.
Okay.
I don't,
there's only a few things I've seen like that.
I saw this fat guy in Seattle one time.
He walked by me and he was gradually picking up speed with the momentum of his
fucking weight and he went by me and I felt this wind,
it was unreal.
Really is like,
I really is a fucking drug.
Um,
I really believe that I didn't before,
but I can tell you,
uh,
just go veggie for two days,
man.
Okay.
That's like the shit that what's said Shit.
They get Methadone or something to get you off the heroin.
They'll listen to me.
I don't what the fuck I'm talking about.
Um,
so anyways,
back to Vegas.
So we had the Monday off me,
Bart,
nick,
law head and [inaudible] and uh,
so we want to bet on something we're bored shitless,
does nothing to bet on.
So we ended up betting on me.
But Nick and Versie bet on Albania to beat the,
the Germans,
I think they'll play in Germany.
I don't fucking know.
And we sat there,
we put money on Albanian a,
when I put 100 bucks on them,
the win.
And then I put 25 bucks down on a tie.
It was basically one,
one,
two,
two zero,
zero are nil nil.
As they say.
After 90 minutes I'd went.
So I don't think I've ever been that interested in a fucking soccer game in my
life.
And I'm telling you,
I learned the secret to all Americans who don't give a fuck about world cup
soccer.
If you want to give a shit but 100 bucks on the,
on the underdog,
you will find yourself sitting on the edge of your seat.
I got a picture of us sitting there in the casino and we our eyes,
you would think we were watching the final two minutes of a fucking super bowl
and Joe Montana's got the ball.
That's how much we were watching this shit.
And in the beginning when Albania is,
we thought scored,
we thought they scored,
we lost our fucking minds.
We jumped up,
right?
And there was all these other people who are from Albania and they've got such a
kick out of the fact that these three white dudes were absolutely losing their
shit.
You know that Albania scored
well.
Yeah.
Now clearly we would.
They would think,
wow.
Well how come they're not for the though the whities there in Germany.
Um,
but of course this unbelievable pass this guy at an unbelievable,
and the fucking ball goes into the net.
We lose our mind,
right?
The guy did a one timer with his head.
We go fucking nuts.
Like,
well,
watch the Stanley Cup playoffs.
And guess what?
Guess what it was offsides.
Can you believe it?
I can't fucking believe it.
It was fucking off sides.
It's always off sides.
It's always fun.
I tweeted that.
So one thing I learned about world cup soccer,
anytime it gets exciting,
that means it's off sides.
The amount of fucking times and how the defensive line could just stop and then
make you offline.
Start running your pussy.
I have to slow down cause you slowed down.
I swear to God.
Yeah.
I swear to God,
man.
If I had enough money to start a soccer league,
I would teach the world how to play that fucking game and I would get just the
same way the NHL rid of the fucking red line,
that bullshit.
I put a fucking blue line out there just like in hockey.
All right,
and once a year in the fucking zone.
That's it.
If somebody can run faster than you,
then guess what?
He's going to take a nice fucking shot at that Goddamn goal that's as big as a
fucking house and we're going to start having some nine to eight games.
Okay.
Poor bastards running around for eight miles
to have a game be nothing to nothing.
Sure.
I want 105 bucks.
That was something like that.
I think I ended up being up 20.
I lost a hundred on Albania to win,
but I,
I got the tie and this is how fucking dumb we were when it went into extra time
and Germany scored the goal,
we were like,
ah,
Shit.
And we got up and we walked out and everybody else was sitting there and I'm
thinking like,
oh,
they must be waiting to watch the next game.
And then we go up to the pool,
took a steam,
went out to the fucking pool,
just acting like idiots.
I kept introducing Paul Versey every woman that would walk by and be like,
excuse me Ma'am Ma'am Ma'am Ma'am,
just want to let you know New Jersey Zone.
Paul Versey I just thought you should know that he is in your presence right
now.
And I swear to God for some reason that was working.
Um,
but anyways,
so we end up having a drink in like fucking Pina coladas.
I don't think I've ever had a peanut out of my life,
but it just made sense.
It was like 108 degrees out and it's like that drink is mostly ice.
And it has an umbrella.
Maybe I can hold it over my nose and try not to get a sunburn there,
so I'm drinking that shit and afterwards,
later on that night we're getting hammered at some bar and we start watching the
highlights of Albania waiting to see that goal that didn't count and then see
the German goal in the extra time that we thought ended it and we're sitting
there watching it.
Germany scores and then Albania scores and then Germany scores ends up being two
to one.
We like,
wait a minute,
what the fuck happened here?
This is still the same.
This is a game from earlier,
earlier this,
this season.
What the fuck is this?
I guess with extended time it just kept,
keeps going.
We thought it was like sudden death.
The first guy who scores wins.
So we fucking walked out.
I mean it didn't change our our bed at all,
but now the looks on the people's faces.
When we got up and walked out,
it made a lot more sense to sort of look of confusion like where are they going?
Where are those fun loving Americans?
That flipped out more than we did.
Where the fuck are they going?
So,
so I learned that.
I still think it's a great game.
I know I've shit all over it,
but it's just fun.
It's fun.
And knowing people from other countries,
you know,
I enjoy the game.
All right.
Uh,
I do find it extremely confusing.
I find the uniforms unbelievably fucking confusing.
Okay.
Like I was sitting there,
uh,
I don't know where the fuck I was in the Netherlands versus Costa Rica Zone.
All right.
I've been to both places.
I got treated great in both places.
So I'm like,
well,
who the fuck do I root for?
And then I find out that Costa Rica is the under dog.
So I'm like,
all right,
I'll go with the underdog.
The Costa Rican is right.
And then I'm sitting there,
I'm trying to figure out which team is which.
Okay.
Because they both have like red,
white and blue flags as far as I know.
But like one team is wearing fucking orange,
all orange.
And I'm like,
I don't know who the fuck is who I'm looking at the uniforms.
I'm trying to find a flag.
And finally what you gotta do is you've got to racially profile him to figure
out who the fuck is,
you know,
and then you know,
there's always going to be a couple of black dudes or something like that.
Somebody with a Tan.
So it's gonna throw you off when you go on.
Like,
okay,
he looks like he looks like he's from the Netherlands.
He looks like he's from no law.
That guy looks like he's from Africa.
I don't fucking know.
You ain't got to sit there for 90 minutes and wait til somebody scores and see
what the fuck number goes to figure out who the hell's hill wasn't that bad.
It took me,
but it honestly took me a good,
like a minute and a half,
two minutes to figure out who the fuck was,
who.
I don't think that's right.
And I don't like that creepy moment too where they hold hands with children and
walk out.
All right.
There's been too much coverage of fucking,
uh,
pedophiles and that type of stuff as an American in my country,
they got everything.
They,
they've made kids weird.
You don't,
you don't touch them.
You don't go near him.
You don't hold their fucking hands.
Okay.
I guess it makes it safe because everybody's looking,
but it's just,
it's really fucking creepy.
You know,
taking their hands and you're walking them out onto the pitch.
That's like when you're in a titty bar and you're dumb enough to go get the
private dance.
She takes you by your hand and she walks out in the back.
It's just,
it's fucking creepy.
You don't do that.
All right?
You don't have them run through fountains in public either with no shirt on.
Okay.
They want to do that shit.
You do it in the backyard.
Okay.
That's your kid.
Fucking turn on that little fucking sprinkler in the back.
Have the kid run through that shit.
You don't bring him down to the God damn mall like they do in Columbus,
Ohio.
Whenever I do the funny bone out there,
it's a bunch of fucking little kids doing a fucking wet t shirt concert,
um,
contest.
Right.
I swear to God,
if I was,
if I were,
if I worked for the special victims unit,
that's where I would park my ass on a slow week and I would just look for
somebody and join that shit a little bit too much.
Um,
so anyways,
so that was the deal.
I made money on roulette.
I made money twice.
I made money,
uh,
throwing dice.
I made money on the tie of Albania.
I wasn't Benton big,
but I would just,
I would,
I would lose a little early and then I would win.
And then I just walked away and I was fucking done.
So I think in the end I probably made somewhere between two and 300 bucks and
that was about it.
That was about it.
All right.
And,
uh,
other than that,
I haven't been doing shit all week.
I'm trying to forget my last hour,
hour and a half of material,
uh,
went out last night.
I did a little bit of stand up.
I got a,
I got one new fucking five minute block starting over again.
I Dunno,
I got nothing.
I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
Um,
what else did anybody,
uh,
anybody watched the,
the UFC last night?
Yeah,
that Erickson Guy,
whatever the fuck his name is.
Fonte Benicio Del Toro.
What was it?
Benicio del Toro head with Brad Pitt's torso from fight club.
MMM.
First three rounds were kind of boring and then it got,
and it got good.
I got really fucking good.
And Ronda Rousey,
Ronda Rousey over the fuck you say her name?
She fucking a dude.
She beat up the check that she was fighting the way my older brother used to
beat me up.
You know,
I'd get a couple in and then he just put me in a headlock,
throw me over his hip and then just give me a bunch of nuggies except there was
no,
there was no ref to break it up.
I was actually upset when the referee broke it up and I didn't realize that her
arm had gone limp.
Jesus Christ,
she took like seven punches right to the forehead.
You know what's funny about the UFC?
Like,
you just can't fucking,
you can never get over there quick enough.
At least in boxing when you get fucking knocked out,
you'd go down and the guy goes to the other corner and that sport,
they rush you when they fucking wet desert with digit with daddy banging and
banging and banging and the fucking ref is coming over like you always take like
another three,
four.
I Dunno,
have it said that I still love the sport and a verse,
he always gives me shit.
He fucking texted me last night.
He goes,
uh,
I texted him,
I said,
hey,
I'm watching that sport yet you'll love,
cause he's always shitting on it and watching the UFC.
And he said,
uh,
he goes,
I'm watching it too.
And he goes,
uh,
he goes,
I like the UFC.
I just think boxing is better.
And I texted him back.
I was like,
yeah,
I kind of guessed that the first 18 times you told me that he's one of those
guys who always hypes up.
Boxing is like the sweet science.
We have a called it the sweet science first.
I don't think ever got fucking knocked out.
You know what we called it the sweet science never talked to a boxer that's in
his fifties and sixties and is dealing with the fucking brain trauma.
I mean I totally respect boxing.
You have sick,
I think,
you know they're fucking warriors.
But um,
I just hate people who attack the UFC and they just go,
they have to fucking rolling around the ground and it looks like two guys about
ready to fuck each other.
It's just like,
I understand a little bit who's getting new?
The guard is basically missionary position except somebody who's trying to
fucking,
you know,
knock your fucking block off.
Other than that,
okay.
I guess it's a,
I guess it is a sexual position,
but um,
I will say this,
people who just always say that,
you know,
do it.
If they went up against the box,
there were a box,
it would blow blah,
blah,
blah.
I don't think so.
I think it's like 50,
50.
Cause I remember when,
uh,
what was it?
Tim Von Maniac.
Sylvia fought that,
what the fuck was that guy's name?
He had like the hardest head ever and he tried to grab him by the back of his
neck and pull him down and fucking give him a knee to the head and the guy just
threw an uppercut and knocked out Tim Silvia.
I think it would be about 50 50
but I would have to get after a while,
I would think the UFC guys would learn to deal with the danger of a boxer's
hands because I don't think anybody in the UFC can box is good as a professional
boxer cause that's all they fucking do.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm sure this is some quarterbacks in the NFL that can kick the ball,
you know,
can actually do a halfway decent punt,
but they're not going to be better than the punter who sits there stretch in his
fucking leg until he can do a total split.
Then never going to kick it farther than that guy.
Cause that's all he does.
So I would think even Muhammad Ali and his fucking prime
would have a hard time going 50 50 if all he knew was boxing because I would
think that 50% of the time maybe he could catch the person as they came in and
tried to shoot his legs and I know,
I don't know shit about this all you fight fans fucking relax.
All right,
I got an hour here to kill.
This is me just,
you know,
I took a couple of fucking Jujitsu classes and that was it before I was on to
something else.
I was just like,
ah,
this,
this isn't for me.
You know what I mean?
By the time I,
by the time Jiu Jitsu became,
people were doing it,
I was already in my thirties and I was just like,
I'm too fucking old.
If we fucking rolling around on the ground,
you know,
I'm giving up my wallet.
Okay,
I'm at that age and I'm going to pray you don't kill me.
Just tell you what man,
I don't want trouble.
I got a black belt in that.
So anyway,
just just fucking entertain me here.
I would think that if,
uh,
you,
mixed martial artists instead of a UFC guy or a woman,
if they were to fucking fight a professional boxer,
obviously,
you know,
they're throwing hands.
So all I would do,
I would stay outside.
If I had an person's skill,
I would stay outside of their hands and I would just do what Joe Rogan loves the
best the fucking leg kicks and just keep smacking him in the fucking thigh over
and over and over again.
Chop them down.
And then when you shoot the legs the second you get them on their back,
they're fucked.
You have no,
if you have no fucking defense
against somebody that knows how to grapple and ground and pound on the ground,
dude,
you're fucking done.
It's over.
Okay.
Maybe I'm nuts.
Maybe I'm fucking crazy.
I don't know anything about this,
but I'll tell you this right now.
I was actually those,
those,
uh,
the women of the your shoe.
Um,
okay.
Like what's her face?
Ronda Rousey,
what she did to that woman she could do to me.
I mean it will be all she fucking throw my pasty.
Yes,
right over a goddamn hip.
Well I fucking powder of white legs would slam on the ground
and I would,
I dunno what I want and that would just be taking them to the fucking head.
I'd probably be making some really embarrassing like emasculating fucking noise
in or I'm feeling like woo.
And that way I would lose consciousness.
I think if I ever dated somebody,
I was married to a woman that was as good a fighter as Rhonda is.
I would literally the amount of times
how would be like,
okay,
okay.
You know,
just,
let's just talk this out.
All right.
Just because you could,
she would literally be beating the shit out of me.
What am I going to do?
Am I going to report it?
I couldn't.
That one I'd have to do is on the side.
I would have to start taking some classes just as a man,
I can't fucking report this shit.
I'd have to start taking some classes to somehow get some sort of defense
against her,
throwing me across the fucking living room.
And then once the first time she ever saw any sort of beyond what the fuck I
knew,
you know,
or what are you taking classes behind my back.
And then she kicked the shit out of me.
Even worse.
Okay.
Oh my God.
See,
this is why I wish the Chappelle show was still on.
How funny would fucking Dave Chappelle B and a God damn sketch
yeah.
About dating the UFC female champion and pissing her off,
remembering the Rick James Sketch when he gets kicked in the air and he landed
on that dresser,
just imagine them using the same special effects of him getting thrown over that
one of those judo throws.
Jesus Christ.
That reminded me of,
of when I w I remember when in the late eighties,
um,
when you use the fucking like her fight her,
her title defense,
that reminded me of Tyson in his prime as far how quickly it was over.
Do you remember that shit?
Anybody else of age that they remember ordering the Tyson fight?
Guys,
come on over.
I got to Tyson fight and like
Tyson,
the fight ended before the pizza got there and everyone was just standing around
and fucking eating a pizza that was too hot to bite into just going through
those fucking bullshit cause like 45 bucks.
I still remember where I was winning and uh,
when he beat Michael Spinks,
a buddy of mine,
we were in his newly finished basement.
Um,
the same basement I watched when Larry Bird stole the ball from Isaiah Thomas
and had a nice low ceiling.
I remember that.
I jumped up and scrape my knuckles like raising Arizona.
Um,
I remember we were,
we were there watching the fight and uh,
we were beside ourselves,
couldn't fucking believe it cause we didn't understand back then,
you know,
the whole fucking liver punch and all that shit.
We just didn't get it.
We were like,
how the fuck is this guy?
Why should,
I think he took one to the head at that point.
It took a shot to the side and then in the last,
you'd already gone down like fucking three times over and like 90,
91 seconds.
And we were pissed.
He was funny.
His house was the house that always ordered the fight.
I watched like the first wrestle mania over there.
God Damn it.
Those were good times.
Good fucking time.
So anyways,
um,
I still totally respect a boxing.
I respect all of that Shit,
man.
I wish I knew how to do that stuff.
I wish I could learn that shit without getting a brain damage,
you know?
Um,
so anyways,
what do you guys think if Floyd Mayweather,
cause that's the thing versus he always brings up,
oh did we had a fucking,
we had a fucking epic argument where we're Versie was trying to say,
I'm going to get him in trouble here because everyone's gonna fucking right into
his podcast.
He was trying to say that may weather would have beaten Hagler Hearns Duran and
sugar ray Leonard.
And I was trying to say,
look,
you know,
at best he goes two and two.
Okay.
I'm not trying to disrespect him and I'm not trying to disrespect them in verse,
he just kept going.
He still fastest fighter ever.
That's what they said.
He has the fastest hands ever.
It's like,
okay,
okay.
Yeah.
The,
the guys calling the fight who are selling the fight,
who are trying to convince you that you are not wasting your money by ordering
the paper view.
Yes.
They're hyping him up is the greatest,
fastest and all that fucking shit.
But,
uh,
you know,
I dunno.
So me lie had in him gotten this screaming matches.
Barnett sat there laughing as we were in this great steakhouse at the Mirage.
Unbelievable fucking stakes.
Unbelievable fucking stakes we had.
And uh,
we would like to what was us and there was one other family that was like across
the restaurant.
We basically closed the place down and we got into such a fucking match about
whether or not Hagler Hearns or whatever could beat Floyd Mayweather.
I remember looking over and there was two waiters at the other side of the
restaurant just laughing at us,
but Ivers he was convinced that,
uh,
may,
I don't know.
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't watch it much.
Boxing didn't know.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't see Mayweather knocking anybody out.
Uh,
I dunno.
I always thought Hagler was the best out of all of them,
even though he lost to sugar ray Leonard.
I thought that was bullshit.
I thought he won that fight and uh,
I gotta hand it to him.
He fucking lost that fight.
Said this is bullshit.
He left,
he moved to Italy,
became an action hero.
Right.
And I never heard of him since.
I bet his brain is pretty much intact.
So good on him.
You know,
Bart,
nick is convinced that he fucking threw the fight and that's why he immediately
went to Italy afterwards.
It became an action hero story.
So that didn't make any fucking sense.
Um,
I don't know if what he looked visibly upset at the end of the fight.
He's saying like,
this is why you don't fight Vegas and Yada,
Yada,
Yada and all this other fucking bullshit.
So many ways.
Um,
all right.
How far,
oh,
41 minutes in
Jesus Christ.
Uh,
I got a hype,
a couple of things here for this week.
Um,
I got a,
I'm doing a benefit for hungry children,
children who are hungry in Brooklyn.
Next week we'll have the link up on my Twitter page,
a at the m m podcast and a Monday and Tuesday I will be out there doing a set,
um,
and uh,
I guess out in Brooklyn,
so I'll be back in New York with that heat,
humidity and all of that fucking horse shit.
And uh,
then I'm immediately flying right back here cause um,
yeah,
I'm on vacation.
I'm a fucking vacation over year.
I'm also,
I've got to ask some people if you already don't,
don't know shit about a fighting it on and I'll type of stuff obviously from the
last five minutes of this podcast.
But I got to ask you my dog sometimes when we're hiking,
I don't know if it's cause she's hot or what,
but all of a sudden she just wants to eat every piece of grass on the hike and
she eats it until she pukes.
I don't understand what the fuck that is.
Um,
I bring water,
I offer her water,
she doesn't want it and she keeps eating the grass,
then she puked and then she's to hydrated.
Then she drinks the shit out of the water.
So basically what I've been doing is I've been,
you know,
cause he's the hotter months,
I just decided I'm going to take a run shorter hikes,
uh,
earlier in the morning.
And I noticed,
you know,
she wasn't doing a lot of that trying to eat grass shit.
So I can't tell if she,
you know,
just as a sensitive stomach,
I don't know what's going on.
So if I figure,
if I gave my 2 cents about a fighting and I don't know shit,
I might as well listen to you fucking,
we can worry.
A dog whisperer is what the fuck you think it is?
I guess I could Google it,
right?
I don't fucking know.
So anyways,
what else the fuck did I want to talk about?
I think that that was it.
All right,
let me do a,
let me do my last bit of reeds here on the podcast here for the,
uh,
for the advertising for this week before I get into a juice.
Remind everybody once again,
if you'd like to donate to the podcast without donating,
just go to a bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page and click on the Amazon link.
Anytime you're going to go to Amazon,
if you think you're going to buy something,
if you take that extra step,
I get credit for sending traffic there and they kicked me a little.
Uh,
thanks for sending traffic here.
It doesn't cost you extra money.
It is an extra step if you don't want to do what I get it.
But I'd appreciate it if you would.
Um,
and with that,
here's some more wonderful reads from bill.
Burn the future.
Well,
Hey,
guess what?
There was only one ad read this week.
Um,
so back to the podcast.
You fucking cause he says Christ,
did I butcher those or did I not?
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
last but not least,
all of a sudden everybody's getting a drone and I'm calling it right now.
Somebody with a drone is going to kill somebody.
They're going to take down a fucking helicopter or a small fucking plane.
I did to have just anybody in the world be able to buy those things and fly them
around.
I cannot fucking believe that that is legal.
Okay.
No flight plan,
no radio contact,
no pilot,
no nothing.
Does drone flying around up there?
Do you know when you ride in a helicopter,
you're not allowed to have anything in your pockets,
especially if the fucking doors are off.
Is anything a cell phone?
Anything goes into that fucking railroader.
You immediately have to put that fucker neutral and auto rotate down to the
ground.
Okay.
Can you imagine
what's going to happen?
I'm one of these fucking drones.
I swear to God.
Where the fuck is the FAA?
Okay.
On this one,
I really hope they don't allow people to get these things to the level that
they're going to get them.
What's funny already as perverts or seeing the advantage of them,
and I've,
I've watched a couple youtube videos and there's women that have accused,
they've taken pictures of these guys that are bringing these cameras up and
they're hovering outside of like a,
you know,
these high rise apartments trying to look into people's,
well,
this is just going to be like,
I swear to God in the future,
I literally think everything is going to be filmed.
You're going to have no fucking privacy whatsoever.
You're going to have to stay in your house with the God damn shades drawn.
And then someone will come up with some technology,
some infrared seed through the shades fucking app that people can use for the
love of God.
Get a fucking life.
If you want to get a pile,
you want to fly,
get the balls to get a fucking pilot's license,
fucking asshole.
You're going to fly that thing around up there and on almost,
you know,
potentially kill somebody while you're safe on the goddamn ground.
I dunno,
ain't right,
man.
Hey,
right.
Bill Burns says it ain't right a little.
We're back.
Um,
okay.
All right.
He's got it here.
Let listeners know that the all things,
comedy has added good times with Steve.
Sumome.
There you go.
Or some,
I don't know how to say his name.
Um,
oh wait.
We had our first live part,
uh,
first live podcast last week where we did an auction and all that.
I want to thank everybody who called in,
people who gave me shit and all that type of stuff.
We had a great fucking time.
Um,
yeah
and uh,
we're definitely going to,
we're going to start doing one of those once a month,
bring it on.
Some of the sties are the all things comedy network.
Uh,
we're having a great time.
We're,
I'm this network and it's a slow burn,
but slowly but surely it is building momentum and uh,
thanks you guys for listening to all the great podcasts that are out there on
the network.
So,
uh,
keep listening.
All right,
and here we go.
Yo,
Yoko ono added again multiple emails from people sending the following link of
Yoko Ono at the Glastonbury festival this summer.
Oh yeah.
I made fun of Yoko in a long time ago.
I gotta be honest.
You'll go on and when the plastic band,
whatever,
plastic ono band or whatever,
the band is fucking great.
Yeah.
And I gotta tell you as far as this video for Yoko Ono,
her singing isn't that bad.
She'd actually be pretty decent at a,
uh,
okay.
And a fucking Karaoke.
A thing of a g there.
I Dunno if you want to seem some more bad Yoko ono or actually good Yoko
warnings.
Oh No.
Singing,
which is sort of just bad singing.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the questions for this week here.
Uh,
summertime blue.
Hey there,
Billy weed whacker.
Uh,
I'm sitting in my cubicle and I'm hating my life.
It's summertime.
My kids are hanging by the pool with my wife and I have friends who have cooler
jobs that allow them more time off to travel and hang out this right.
Well,
first of all,
dude,
the fact that you have a wife and kids at home and you've got a cubicle job,
you're,
you're crushing it.
You know,
I always thought those cubicle job they gave you the little skinny Michael J.
Fox tie and that's all you got.
Um,
anyways,
this Rut has me thinking about the good times I used to have riding my bike,
playing baseball and hanging out with friends all day till it got dark and then
playing some video games once the mosquitoes got too bad.
What are your favorite summertime memories?
What do you miss the most?
Um,
what do I miss the most?
Oh yeah.
You know what it is,
is you just,
I just,
I just wish there was a way they conveyed to a kid a mortgage,
you know,
being in a relationship,
uh,
property tax,
you know,
nine to five job term papers,
all of this shit that you have to do,
counting calories,
all of that fucking crap.
I just wish there was a way that,
you know what I miss.
I miss my problems that I had as a kid that I thought were huge.
That's what I miss.
You know,
as someone was picking on me at school that there was some girl I liked and I
didn't know what to say.
You know,
oh that the Sunday papers are coming and they're going to be really heavy
when I go to deliver him.
Those were my problems.
Oh,
it's raining today on my paper route,
dude.
I had,
I had the fucking,
I had the best childhood when I really go back and think about it,
you know,
I had a paper route so I always from third grade on,
I had a paper.
I always had a fucking job.
So I always had money.
I used to make like,
like 18 bucks a week.
Okay.
When you don't have a car payment,
you don't have a mortgage.
We don't have to pay for food.
When you have zero fucking expenses and all your into his fucking candy bars and
football cards,
$18
in a pack of football cards was 35 cents a pack and it came with a piece of gum.
Oh,
it was unbelievable.
We had this,
we used to live in this old house.
It was a,
uh,
we lived in the front and these other people lived in the back of,
it was this beautiful.
I mean it was run down,
but I mean,
you could,
you could.
It's the reason why I bought this old house that I have,
I have the appreciation for the woodwork and stuff.
And um,
when I always thought was cool was that it had two stairways,
like a lot of old houses have a stairway in the front and the stairway in the
back.
And I always thought that that was cool as shit.
But what they did was they put dividers up in the middle and built another
kitchen in the back and the back stairway was a smaller place.
And then the front,
we have the bigger one because we have a bigger family.
And uh,
this fucking place had unfinished Blair witch basement,
like one of those turn of this century,
last century,
I should say.
Uh,
foundations that always had the smell of dampness and all of that shit that was
downstairs.
We had a ping pong table,
which was just an unfinished piece of plywood with a net on it.
And the in the paddles,
right.
A bunch of other shit down there and spiders.
We play that down there.
And you had the Washer and dryer down there,
which we had up on two by fours because every time it fucking rained it flooded
down there.
Um,
and the pump never worked.
Like he had to go down there and put on your big fucking rain boots and turn on
the pump.
And
then on the next floor up there was a dining room,
a living room and a kitchen.
And then you went up the stairs and the woodwork,
the banister and all that was fucking incredible.
Like I said,
it needed a little Tlc,
but then you went upstairs and to the right was a bedroom and to the left was
two other bedrooms.
And then there was another bathroom.
And um,
and then yeah,
when you went to the bathroom,
there was another door that led up to a third floor that had two more rooms up
there.
Like,
you didn't have to crouch down.
It was this old fucking house.
But up there,
you know,
we didn't have any AC in that house.
In the second floor was bad enough and you got up on the third floor and you'd
like literally risked fucking heat stroke.
And that was this incredible old house that we rented for the majority of my
childhood and next to it had this giant field.
And um,
we used to go out there all summer.
We played baseball during baseball season.
During the winter we played football.
Uh,
my dad put up a basketball rim and it was funny,
he wasn't a sports guy and he thought on regulation room was nine feet.
So we had a nine foot fucking basketball rim on a slanted fucking driveway.
The one that I sucked at that sport.
Uh,
yeah,
we used to ride bikes,
all of that shit before video games or the Internet and all that.
You just went outside climb trees.
We used to climb up this fucking tree.
I lived at like 2015 minutes south of Boston.
Yeah.
I don't know what it was.
I don't know.
So we probably like 10,
12 miles outside the city.
And we used to climb up a tree that was high enough that we could see the
potential building and the John Hancock building two biggest buildings in,
uh,
in Boston.
You know,
both insurance companies go figure,
right?
They never fucking pay anybody.
Um,
we used to climb all the way up those fucking things.
We will,
we will that will member of this,
this fucking a town pool.
We'd ride our bikes down there.
We just stayed down at the pool from one to seven every fucking day.
Swimming all day.
Just had no fucking war zone.
You're,
you'll life was a vacation was fucking ridiculous.
And all you had was just bullshit homework.
And I was such a pussy.
I couldn't even get through doing homework.
It might,
life was a fucking joke.
My life has never been better was it was never better.
And you just don't even realize it when you didn't have rent yet.
No fucking worries.
Sitting around eating fucking candy bars,
you don't even get fat.
Fucking hilarious.
So that's what I miss.
I miss all of that.
All of that Shit,
those fucking,
uh,
elementary school days right into like junior high.
And once you started getting into junior high,
then that's when people really started to break off into cliques.
People started their first fucking drinking and drug abuse and then all the
bullshit starts and all that fucking crap.
That's what kind of where it went off the rails for me.
Um,
but um,
yeah man,
I miss all of that shit.
It's fucking perfect dude.
When you don't have any expenses and you make an $18 a week and your hobby cost
you 35 cents a whack,
I mean it's,
you're the king of the world.
So yeah,
I miss all of that.
I miss all of that shit.
That's what I would say.
Um,
let me get it.
The question is,
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
I guess that was a question I got so involved in that.
I forgot it was all right.
My friend is now a woman.
Oh,
JJ too.
He whose hair is red and whose balls or blue?
I am a 25 year old man and one of my close friends from high school who I still
see somewhat regularly,
recently told me that he's,
he is transgender.
You know,
I don't know what that means.
Let me look that up.
I always get trans transvestite means you just wear women's clothes.
Let me get this right.
Trans Gender.
Here we go.
Transgender according to Wikipedia is the state of one's gender identity.
Self identification as woman,
man,
neither or both.
Or gender expression,
not matching.
One's assigned sex.
Also.
You don't have to get a,
so a transsexual then as if you had the sex change.
You know what this is like.
This is like trying to spell like psycho psychology,
psychosis,
psychotic.
I don't fucking know all those.
all his fucking things.
I could never keep them straight.
Um,
identification by other,
by others as male,
female or Intersex based on physical.
Slash.
Genetics.
Sex.
This is already over my head.
Transgender is independent of sexual orientation.
Sexual orientation.
What does that,
what does sexual orientation,
what you're into.
Now I gotta look on this,
right?
Sexual orientation is an enduring personal quality,
and then clients you people to feel romantic or sexual attraction to persons of
the opposite,
sex or gender,
the same sex.
All right,
so basically gay,
straight bi.
Okay,
so that mystery,
oh my God,
this is like quicksand.
It just keeps going further.
Transgender is independent of who you want to fuck.
Let's put this in layman's term.
Transgender people may identify as heterosexual,
homosexual,
bisexual,
pansexual.
Yeah.
Pansexual.
Paulie,
sexual or asexual.
I know what asexual is.
I know a bisexual.
What is pansexual?
Why would you have a globe?
Uh,
pants.
Sexual or sexuality
is sexual attraction,
sexual desire,
romantic love or emotional attraction toward people of any sex or gender
identity.
Okay.
Oh,
so that's not bisexual.
We like you into men and women.
This goes to the next level where you're also went to transsexuals.
Jesus.
You know what?
This,
this seems like,
you know when those word problems in math,
oh my God,
look at this.
You know this fucking,
okay.
Polysexual it looks polysexual.
You know,
you know the male signing the female sign,
the sign for polysexual looks like that sign that prince changed himself to
Paulie.
Sexuality is the attraction to multiple genders.
Okay.
And or sexist,
what do they mean?
Multiple genders?
There's does two genders.
You,
they're a man or a woman,
right?
Or is a transsexual,
okay,
I'm already lost.
Is that considered a gender?
A polysexual PR.
If you run for office,
do you have to know this shit so you don't fuck this up?
President borough,
how much is this dozen eggs costs?
I don't fucking know.
I got a private chef.
Uh,
polysexual person is one encompassing or characterizing characterized by many
different kinds of sexuality.
Poly Sexuality is sexual identity used by people who recognize that the term
bisexual,
and I can't even read this word.
S the gender dichotomy that underlines the distinction between heterosexuality
and homosexuality.
Was that what it is?
I have no,
I don't fucking,
I don't even know.
All right,
so
Jesus fucking Christ you.
It's funny the amount of people that could read that and totally get it.
I just,
it just all becomes fucking Mumbo jumbo to me.
All right.
I can't even remember what transgender
did.
Okay.
He actually said this means that even though he's a physically a man,
he identifies as a woman.
Okay.
He told me that he isn't thinking about getting surgery or anything major like
that,
but wants to try living as a woman from now on.
Oh,
he just became way more difficult to buy four,
didn't he?
Okay,
guys are easy to buy now.
What do you buy the guy who identifies as a woman that has everything,
you know,
what do you get them some Chanel scarf that's out of print.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
he has always been a little peculiar,
so this didn't exactly come out of left field,
but since telling me this,
he slash she has begun wearing unflattering women's clothing.
That to be blunt,
look fucking gross.
Well,
I bet.
Did he know how to dress when he was a guy?
I mean,
can you give them a little bit of a learning curve?
How would you put together an outfit?
I would go with Yoga Pants and flats.
I would just start like,
you know,
I would dress like a woman online,
very date.
I would ease myself into it,
you know,
before I tried to pull off anything a little more risky,
like
what would I change my name to whatever he Wilma,
Wilma clubbing tonight.
And then what I do,
you know,
I'd have to do some sort of theme like dress like a housewife in the 1950s,
like Rosie the riveter meets fucking a,
okay.
That chicken was bang and Desi Arnaz um,
Lucy,
whatever.
If I don't imagine David Cross prancing around in a skimpy miniskirt anyways,
I want to be supported.
Oh,
he went,
oh,
he dove straight in.
He's dressing like a fucking scag.
Anyways,
I want to be supportive of my friend in this time in their life and don't want
to turn my back on them,
but I don't know how much more I can handle seeing them dress like this and his
slash her new interest in cutesy girly stuff seems contrived.
I've,
I don't think you can really contrive something like that.
You know,
it takes a lot of fucking balls,
which I'm sure you can see hanging out of that small skirt
to walk around.
And that shit he says,
I've thought about suggesting for him slash her to wear more conservative female
clothing,
but don't know how to begin to bring up a subject like that.
Uh,
I would just bring a Barbara Bush,
just see where the conversation goes.
MMM.
Uh,
I dunno what the fuck to tell you here for making suggestion.
Now this is a question.
Do you have to call her her?
I think that's fucking weird.
It's like you clearly a dude.
You still have a Dick,
right?
You know,
and I don't want,
I guess
that's the one of those things where you go like,
yeah,
he's,
he's right over there and then suddenly be like,
she,
she's over there.
People patting themselves on the back.
How politically correct they are.
Oh,
you mean that hairy leg check with the Dick and balls.
Okay.
Is that where she is?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Two plus two is five now.
Okay.
I'm accepting what,
what the with his Jean Skirt.
Isn't that enough?
You're going to come at me about pronouns anyways.
Overall,
this friendship has just proven to be exhausting because I feel like I've lost a
friend I once had and they've become a new person that I don't get along with.
Am I an asshole?
If I stop agreeing to hang out with him slash her and slowly cut them out of my
life?
What would you do?
In my situation,
he slash she has always had a strong personality and many other friends,
so it isn't like I'd be leaving them to be alone,
but am I a bad person if I can't handle being their friend anymore?
Thanks.
Love the podcast and go fuck yourself.
Now if somebody is being irritating,
they're fucking irritating.
All right.
You've accepted their choice,
you know?
I Dunno.
If they're annoying the shit out of you,
then yeah,
you seem like you've accepted the fact like you can't go so liberal even though
they've become a Douche,
that you're going to completely ignore that because you feel like you're now not
accepting.
The fact that he now dresses like is she?
So if you don't have a problem with that,
which you don't seem too,
but the person is still is annoying,
then you know,
don't,
you can't just fucking hang out with them because now they're wearing a dress.
Okay.
You know,
treat them like a regular person if they're fucking irritate and you've got to
cut them out of their life,
out of your life.
That's it.
All right.
Corporations,
Billy CEO,
you're always trashing corporations and rightfully so.
But are there any companies you do,
like if you are a NASCAR driver,
who would you want to be your sponsor or if he did a commercial,
what would it be for?
Go Fuck yourself and come back to Baltimore.
Um,
yeah,
that's a great fucking question.
Um,
I dunno,
I guess a beer company cause I like beer and he sort of booze I would be fine
with.
Other than that,
I would like to try to get somebody,
uh,
I dunno.
So we didn't makes furniture in this country country or somebody who,
uh,
I dunno
fucking re does cars or some,
some that I thought was cool,
but they weren't like,
I certainly wouldn't want a Walmart.
Jesus Cleo the fucking dog collar.
Who would I want?
I Dunno.
I probably be like,
okay.
Some of the beers,
some of the obscure beer companies that I've,
I've found,
you know,
like when I was in Australia,
that little creatures beer that I liked.
MMM.
I would say some shit like that,
I guess.
I Dunno the Nhl just ship that I was into,
maybe a drum company,
but then I could have wasted time putting that shit on the side of a car.
Would they?
Oh the fuck would I have.
That's a great fucking question.
Something unique.
I don't know.
I just like to go out there independent and just have a fucking Badass car with
no sponsor name on it.
Right.
And just to sickest fucking paint job.
Make all those other guys look fucking stupid.
Right.
Then if you actually win.
Yeah.
No.
Shove a fucking,
I don't know what the fuck you'd put on it.
Some of that shit you see on all those cool car shows.
The gas monkey shit.
MMM.
I guess something like that.
Oh God damn it.
This is like when he's back in the day when you'd still had record stores.
I mean,
I mean what makes CD stores when it was virgin and all that shit and you was,
you're walking around during the week.
I'm going to buy this CD and I buy that CD and my Ba.
Then you walk in the store and you couldn't fucking remember anything.
I might have to answer this one next week.
Yeah.
All right.
Or Enough?
No fucking idea.
All right.
Engagement Ring,
Dare Bill Matrimony and buying my girlfriend and engagement ring.
So when I want to get something simple,
I feel like giving something fancy will stress the importance of luxury and
that's not how I want to start our lives together.
Jesus Christ,
I do well and money is not the issue.
I think that if I tied a string around her finger,
that should be enough.
It's assembled,
not a collector's item.
How do I convey this to her?
Also,
please don't act like a chicken.
Tell me how and why it's important to her.
Well,
I mean,
you've basically walled off everything except your opinion.
You sound very fucking controlling and you sound like a cheap fuck.
All right?
So go get her a fucking little piece of string and the,
and conveyed to her the importance of the dollar.
Do that for her.
Everybody loves that.
You know when you throw in a keg party for someone to come around and go,
hey,
let's get it cheap beer.
Okay,
let's only get a quarter keg.
Everybody get as small sippy cup here on this big day of celebration.
This is the biggest day of her fucking young life.
The only day bigger than this is going to be when she gives birth to children.
Okay,
so go ahead with your little strength.
Tie it around her fucking finger.
Ah,
how do you,
how do you say that to her?
Jesus fucking Christ.
How would you like it,
sir?
If once you guys got married and you were going down and you wanted to go down
and you wanted to go buy this new corvette that's coming out the new fucking
zero six,
whatever it is,
it's going to go 200 fucking miles an hour and you were in the God damn money.
And she says no,
and she stresses to you the importance of that fucking shit.
Oh,
I guess you're going to say,
well,
it's my money.
I can do what the fuck I want.
MMM.
I don't know how to give an example.
Um,
all I can say is that I,
I feel bad for this woman cause,
uh,
I dunno.
I don't know.
I feel like if you're with the right woman,
you want to fucking,
yeah.
Buyer.
You know?
I feel like if,
if you fucking
okay,
love your wife.
Okay.
And if you have the funds,
don't you want her to have like a closet full of all the shoe she ever wanted?
Yeah.
You know,
that's like,
that's like her sports package or whatever.
I had going to have all your fucking shoes dress up.
I know you're under the shit.
I know that makes you happy.
Why would I want to deny you that?
Okay,
go get all the fucking shoes you want.
You know,
I don't personally speaking,
I would buy her a a uh,
I dunno.
I would buy,
this is what I would do,
sir.
I would buy a ring that conveys your feelings towards her rather than your
feelings towards your wallet and your concern that she's going to be spending
all of your money.
And if that really is a concern of yours,
that's a major fucking concern.
Cause that's one of the number one things that drives people apart is money.
And if you guys are not on the same page monetarily,
I would really reconsider what the fuck it is.
You're about rugged though.
All right.
They're all right.
They're a control freak.
Fucking cutting all the goddamned Jesus Christ.
Okay.
All right.
This is my impression of this guy on one of his kids birthdays.
All right?
They're all in the other room he's in,
he's in the other room.
Count is fucking money and there and the other ongoing happy.
Yay.
Hey Caitlin.
Tao.
Don't say too loud.
Don't be too happy.
I don't want,
I don't want to set a precedent with that baby's first birthday that,
you know,
this is the how happened.
We got to be even more happy in the next one.
Give her,
give us some place to go.
Quit your crying.
Um,
all right.
And that is the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
Thank you so much for listening.
I,
uh,
I appreciate it,
but he's listening and all that type of shit.
Don't take any crap.
Go fuck yourselves.
I will talk to you next week.
And,
um,
okay.
I think that's it.
Yeah,
that is it.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.